hans jörg vehlewald bei uns im studio
erklär uns nochmal dieses verhältnis
zwischen schröder und putin weiß er doch
ein bisschen merkwürdig ist gerhard
schröder hat mit putin wohl irgendwann
mal aus seiner sicht einen guten plan
ausbaldowert nämlich europa auf dauer
mit gas ein bisschen mit gas aus
russland zu versorgen daraus ist glaube
ich würde sowas wie eine freundschaft
entstand man muss auch überlegen 90er
jahren war auch weil wladimir putin
jemand der von demokratie
demokratisierung auch seines eigenen
landes sparta sind viele hoffnungen
aufgekommen da deren bundestag sprach im
bundestag davon gesprochen dass sind das
waren ein anderer putin auf den hat
schröder gesetzt und auf den hat
schröder sich dann immer mehr
eingelassen muss man ehrlicherweise
sagen und hat irgendwann dann auch nicht
mehr den absprung geschafft was meine
sichtweise wenn man sich anhört was der
in den letzten monaten angefangen mit
mit einer ware oder angefangen habe ich
mit der krim besetzung dann über navalny
den mordanschlag auf den dissidenten
dann anfang des jahres über die säbel
rasseln der ukraine solche geschichten
das war wirklich kaum noch erträglich
das ist so eine männerfreundschaft auf
die halt nichts kommen soll macht den
eindruck heißt es ist auch inzwischen
ein anderer gerhard schröder als den den
wir von damals kennen ja ex-kanzler und
das ist vor allem ein angestellter wie
peter die liga sehr genau sagt das ist
ein angestellter bei einem konzern bei
konzernen die von putin letztlich
geführt werden das ist also mehr kein
wirklich auf augenhöhe sprechen jetzt
haben wir gehört die spd spitze hatte ja
nun eigentlich jungs gefordert er solle
sich jetzt von putin distanzieren und
zwar öffentlich was glaubst du wie sehen
die jetzt diesen besuch er steckt
natürlich ehrlicherweise immer die
hoffnung drin dass so ein besuch
irgendetwas bewirken könnte sie müssen
immer dran denken es geht darum dass im
moment in der ukraine blut fließt
menschen erschossen werden kinder
sterben kinderkrankenhäuser beschossen
werden ehrlicherweise alles an
gesprächen was das jetzt stoppen könnte
muss hoch willkommen sein was mich nur
sehr verwundert ich hab's mir grad
nochmal bestätigen lassen auch aus der
bundesregierung die wissen so sagen sie
definitiv nicht von diesem besuch ist es
nicht abgesprochen worden das ist ein
seltsamer alleingang wenn es denn so
zutrifft und die hoffnung ist vielleicht
klappt ja aber das nicht einmal
abgesprochen dass mit der
bundesregierung diese besuch dann muss
man ehrlicherweise sagen will daher
schröder vielleicht aus seinem ruf ganz
einfach hätte will es seit wochen schon
offenbar allen in der partei zeigen die
ihn jetzt madig machen kommt immer
wieder die sprüche von der euren job
habt ihr doch nur weil ich in euch
gegeben habe und so weiter das ist
eingeschnappt seien bei der passt auch
eigentlich zu ihm und vielleicht will er
sich jetzt mit dieser friedensmission
will er seinen ruf retten als jemand der
es am ende ja vielleicht doch geschafft
hat glaubst du denn er kann tatsächlich
wirklich was erreichen wie viele chancen
rechnest du da aus dazu muss man erstens
in den kopf und schulter gucken und dann
auch noch nicht von putin über den wir
uns die ganze zeit schon viele gedanken
machen ich kann das nicht wirklich
beurteilen ich glaube nicht dass wenn
putin einen festen plan hat ob das die
besetzung erhalten oder der ganzen
ukraine ist die absetzung der regierung
oder was auch immer diese pläne da kann
ich mir schwerlich vorstellen dass ihn
sein alter freund
schröder da wirklich um wird umstimmen
können könnte ihm denn ein kleiner
erfolg tatsächlich in der spd wieder ein
bisschen rehabilitieren zumal sich jetzt
neben schröder nicht ermutigen den
schredder natürlich ja klar also wenn
ihm das gelingt dann müssen alle
ehrlicherweise hinterher kreide fressen
liegen jetzt kritisiert haben aber
völlig zu recht kritisiert haben sich
nicht so dass er nicht putins überfall
auf die ukraine verurteilt hätte aber es
kommt immer wieder der spruch von den
fehlern die auf beiden seiten gemacht
wurden ich habe auch heute mit sigmar
gabriel dazu gesprochen der den brief
nicht unterschrieben hat und er sagt
halt es ist vor allem ein brief der
diejenigen die ihn unterzeichnen auch
exkulpieren sondern wie er sagt also
ihnen aus der patsche helfen darunter
ist immer eine matthias platzeck der nun
auch seit jahren darauf dafür kritisiert
wird wie eng er mit putin koste es was
es wolle immer wieder an wandelt hans
hat fehler bei dankeschön für deine ganz
aktuelle einschätzung ja das ist ja
schon eine wirklich erstaunliche meldung
die uns da erreicht hat wir sehen hier
auch immer wieder die fotos die bilder
die wladimir putin und gerhard schröder
zusammen zeigen eine wirklich enge
männerfreundschaft hat auch hans jörg
vehlewald eben noch mal bestätigt nun
soll er eben so als friedensstifter in
moskau unterwegs sein bei mir im studio
jetzt der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der cdu/csu-fraktion
thorsten frei sonntag herr frei was
haben sie gedacht als sie das gehört
haben das hat mich zunächst einmal
sprachlos gemacht auch wenn wir über die
umstände die in mutmaßlich nach moskau
geführt haben natürlich nur spekulieren
können aber angesichts der vorgeschichte
angesichts der tatsache dass wir das
erste mal einen deutschen ehemaligen
bundeskanzler haben der im grunde
genommen nicht eine rolle als elder
statesman einnimmt sondern sozusagen als
angestellter von vladimir putin der hier
als aggressor als als kriegstreiber
auftritt agiert das ist schon etwas ganz
neues und etwas ganz außergewöhnliches
und deswegen macht es natürlich auch
misstrauisch wenn es jetzt meldungen
gibt er sei in moskau natürlich wünschen
wir uns alle dass wenn er tatsächlich
jetzt auch da ist dass er dann auch was
erreicht bei wladimir putin trauen sie
ihm das zu ich weiß es nicht in der
vergangenheit hat er ja nicht gerade
dadurch begrenzt dass er interessen
deutschlands oder europas in moskau
vertreten hätte sondern es ging ums
schnöde geld und er hat funktionen
übernommen die für putin hilfreich waren
seine eigenen wirtschaftlichen und
politischen interessen durchzusetzen
also im grunde hinsehen als
steigbügelhalter für putin bezeichnen
ich glaube so kann man das was die
vergangenheit anbelangt durchaus
bezeichnen etwas was wir nie für möglich
gehalten hätten auch bei einem
ehemaligen deutschen kanzler und
insofern wir haben derzeit keine anderen
anhaltspunkte die da gerhard schröder in
ein milderes licht tauchen würden was
ist das denn jetzt auch für ein signal
was davon ausgeht auch für die
bundesregierung sieht das nicht auch so
ein bisschen so aus als hätten wir hier
in deutschland das alles nicht im griff
und jeder macht jetzt ein eigenes ja es
ist eine ganz außergewöhnliche situation
es war natürlich auch so dass die spd
und auch olaf scholz lange gebraucht
haben bis sie sich distanziert haben von
gerhard schröder das war lange ein
großes problem zwischenzeitlich haben
sie das getan
aber mit sicherheit dafür gibt es ja
auch viele andeutungen ist putin ist
schröder nicht der einzige in der spd
der letztlich so denkt und wo wir eine
große nähe zu putin und russland haben
den meinen sie da konkret beispielsweise
die frau schwesig die sich in diesem
bereich lange und viel engagiert hat es
gibt aber auch einige andere in der spd
insofern ist es tatsächlich so dass die
spd dort auch abgekommen ist von einem
bisherigen weg wieso glauben sie ist das
sowieso hat man sich so in den nähe
sozusagen der russen gegeben anstatt da
ein bisschen mehr abstand zu halten ich
kann da natürlich nur spekulieren und
das ist schwierig bei diesem thema aber
mit sicherheit war es so dass man auch
mit einer gewissen naivität auf putin
geschaut hat
man muss glaube ich ganz offen sagen
dass viele von uns geglaubt haben dass
man mit putin reden kann dass man ihn
beschwichtigen kann dass man auf dem
verhandlungswege gute lösungen erreichen
kann im kern ist putin aber einer der
eben nicht die stärke des rechts sondern
das recht des stärkeren in den
mittelpunkt rückt und deswegen ist es
glaube ich ganz wichtig dass diplomatie
auch nur dann eine chance hat wenn man
sozusagen mit einem starken rücken ihm
entgegen treten kann und das ist eine
der großen lehren die wir dieser tage
ziehen können was erwarten sie jetzt von
der bundesregierung was erwarten sie
jetzt von olaf scholz in dieser frage
wie muss er sich jetzt positionieren im
hinblick auf schröder oder im hinblick
auf die situation in der ukraine und
russland beides ja also zunächst einmal
hat olaf scholz mit seinem vorschlag in
sondervermögen in höhe von 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr zu
machen
sicherlich den richtigen ton
angeschlagen und insbesondere die
tatsache dass er und das ist ja für die
spd etwas neues zukünftig jedes jahr
mehr als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts für sicherheit und
verteidigung ausgeben möchte dass es der
richtige ansatz genau darum geht es und
es werden wir selbstverständlich auch
als opposition unterstützen wir werden
allerdings auch kein blankoscheck
ausstellen sondern wir werden uns sehr
genau schauen was die regierung machen
möchte und wenn sie unsere unterstützung
im falle einer grundgesetzänderung
benötigt dann erwarten wir auch dass wir
darüber sprechen können wie das am ende
auch tatsächlich mit leben erfüllt
werden soll eines der großen probleme in
diesem konflikt ist ja offensichtlich
dass deutschland sich in den letzten
jahren zu abhängig gemacht hat von
energie aus russland wäre es dann jetzt
nicht zu sagen wir müssen unsere
atomkraftwerke doch ein bisschen länger
wieder am netz lassen ja das ist
durchaus eine option auch das ist kein
allheilmittel wir haben ja gerade noch
drei atomkraftwerke in deutschland
bis ende diesen jahres eine vorgesehene
laufzeit haben sie sind zuständig für
drei bis fünf prozent des strombedarfs
in deutschland das produzieren sie aber
in der jetzigen situation da möchte ich
ihnen vollkommen recht geben in der
jetzigen situation wo es um
energieversorgungssicherheit geht wo es
darum geht in einer schwierigen
situation
abhängigkeiten zu verringern darf keine
option vor schnell vom tisch genommen
werden und genau das hat die
bundesregierung gemacht der
wirtschaftsminister und auch die
umweltministerin dass sie mit einem
ideologisch getriebenen gutachten gesagt
haben das ist weder rechtlich noch
technisch möglich da haben wir eine
andere sicht der dinge nicht dass wir
glauben dass das das allheilmittel wäre
aber es ist eine option in der frage wie
schaffen wir es versorgungssicherheit in
diesem und im nächsten winter vor allem
zur hat angela merkel das damals zu
blauäugig zu frühzeitig gemacht dass sie
sozusagen den der atomkraft die absage
erteilt hat war das ein fehler naja wenn
man sich zurückversetzt das jahr 2011
unmittelbar nach dem
reaktorunglück in fukushima muss man
natürlich sagen wir hatten eine ganz
breite gesellschaftliche nicht nur
politische auch gesellschaftliche
mehrheit die gesagt hat uns ist das
risiko von friedlich betriebener
kernkraft zu groß wir möchten da den
ausstieg aber politik sollte doch nicht
nur so handeln wie die mehrheit es gerne
möchte sondern so wie es auch in der
zukunft eben dann auch für die mehrheit
richtig und gut ist oder ja
selbstverständlich also beides muss man
im behalten in der demokratie ist es
natürlich durchaus entscheidend was eine
mehrheit will und für richtig hält in
dieser situation insofern muss man das
beides im blick behalten man hat
natürlich ein großes wagnis eingegangen
indem man sozusagen den ausstieg aus den
fossilen energieträgern und der ausstieg
aus der kernenergie quasi zeitgleich
vorangetrieben hat und das hat dazu
geführt dass wir gewaltige
herausforderungen gewärtigen und es hat
eben auch dazu geführt dass wir sehen
müssen es geht um co2 neutralität es
geht um kosten des erlebten die menschen
ja nicht zuletzt auch an den zapfsäulen
es geht aber auch um
versorgungssicherheit für unsere
unternehmen und die wirtschaft und das
muss man im blick behalten und das
erwarte ich auch von der bundesregierung
dass sie sozusagen auch in form einer
sensitivitätsanalyse mal schaut welche
politischen entscheidungen dann welche
auswirkungen auf unsere
energieversorgung und damit auch auf
unsere wirtschaft und wir wollen direkte
zu paul ronzheimer schauen nach kiew
paul zunächst einmal diese meldung die
uns ja alle erreicht hat gerhard
schröder soll in moskau sein was sagst
du dazu
das ist auch gerade das gesprächsthema
hier in kiew ich habe überrascht da
anrufe bekommen von
regierungsberatern die von mir wissen
wollten was da gerade vor sich geht also
hier in der ukraine wusste natürlich
auch niemand davon dass gerhard schröder
ausgerechnet gerhard schröder jetzt bei
wladimir putin sitzen soll in diesen
stunden und ich höre aus berlin aus
regierungskreisen
dass weder der kanzler noch andere
minister die außenministerin informiert
waren und auch dass die spd spitze von
nichts wusste also eine absolute
geheimmission von gerhard schröder viele
fragen sich auch wie ist er da überhaupt
hin gekommen denn es gibt ja keinen
flugverkehr mehr mit europäischen
maschine nach moskau
also entweder hat er dann einen großen
umweg enormen richtung doha zum beispiel
und dann nach moskau oder er ist mit
einer privatmaschine geflogen was
glaubst du paule rechnest du
irgendwelchen friedensverhandlungen die
da eventuell geführt werden irgendeine
chance aus kann schröder da in
irgendeiner form vermitteln
da müssen wir abwarten was da aus diesem
gespräch rauskommen ich glaube nicht
dass er in irgendeiner form die meinung
wladimir putins verändern kann sondern
gehe davon aus dass das ganze eine
abgestimmte propaganda aktion ist eins
darf man ja nicht vergessen gerhard
schröder hat sich bislang weiter
geweigert mit putin zu brechen er hat
weiterhin rosneft und gazprom posten als
er wird weiter von putin bezahlt und er
hat sich zwar vom krieg distanziert aber
eben nicht von wladimir putin die frage
ist ob er möglicherweise
selbst einen persönlichen druck jetzt
verspürt hat denn seine büromitarbeiter
haben ihn verlassen er hat keinen
kontakt mehr zu politikern zu den er
früher kontakt hatte es also wahnsinnig
isoliert möglicherweise auch eben sozial
isoliert also wer will momentan noch mit
gerhard schuler abendessen gehen
angesichts der tatsache dass er für
einen mann weiter arbeitet der mit
seinen raketen hier ein
kinderkrankenhaus beschießen lässt ich
gehe aber davon aus dass schröder ist in
irgendeiner form nutzen will und der
kreml auch nutzen will denn eines darf
man nicht vergessen
wladimir putin weiß genau was er tut und
das macht er jetzt nicht nur als kleinen
gefallen für gerhard schröder sondern
vielleicht sagt man dann wieder gerd
schröder habe darauf hingewirkt dass es
zum beispiel irgendeiner art kommt
humanitären korridor geben könnte und am
ende ist es dann so vielleicht wurde das
schon vorher beschlossen und dann durch
gerhard schröder öffentlich gemacht wer
weiß das sind die spekulationen aber
natürlich will er möglicherweise sich
dort wieder reinwaschen in gewisser
weise und dann das gefühl dass er
irgendetwas erreicht haben könnte nach
deutschland strom paul über friedens
korridore würde heute auch in antalya
gesprochen allerdings ist dieser
friedensgipfel ja relativ ergebnislos zu
ende gegangen wie wird das in kiew
aufgenommen
in kiel wird man nicht überrascht über
das scheitern der friedensverhandlungen
auch der präsidentiellen ski mit dem ich
gestern ein interview geführt habe und
danach auch noch intensiv sprechen
konnte der war nicht davon ausgegangen
dass man einfach schnell diesen diesen
krieg beenden kann bzw dass putin ihn
beenden will sondern dass das ganze
länger dauert der ukrainische
aussenminister kohle hat ja gesagt dass
man weitere treffen vorgeschlagen hat
jetzt ist die frage auf was ist man
bereit in der ukraine einzugehen das
problematische ist sind die forderungen
aus moskau sei diese demilitarisierung
zb das ist kaum zu akzeptieren von
ukrainischer seite kompliziert auch die
frage des status der krim die situation
im donbass wo man verlangt dass man
diese unabhängigkeit akzeptieren und die
forderung dass die ukraine nicht der
nato beitreten soll für den präsidenten
auch ein moralisches dilemma natürlich
will er diesen krieg beenden aber er
will auch dass die ukraine ihre existenz
behält paul dankeschön für den moment
nach kiew